travaux allez on vous non celui le plus
généreux de tqm pdg de vérité assez fou
de l'avancée des moineaux valérie c'est
merci moi merci valérie raymond basse et
vous merci après jean millet généreux
ouais mais comme j'ai rien jean michel
tu vas boire des verres avec lui paye
est vraiment même des pizzas évidemment
je le paie chaud il y à jean-louis dormi
c'est vrai j'y vais ce cas là le coeur
sur la main et généreuse à les
altruistes j'avoue le pen a beaucoup de
souffrance je sois célibataire
oui à brabois c'est valérie anne saint
cado un jour sur deux non c'est plein de
choses tout le temps ouais elle a
toujours mené par vos volets avec bravo
monsieur était avec moi me fait toujours
des cadeaux aussi valérie c'est la plus
généreuse pour moi aussi voilà après la
généreuse de coeur et général généreuse
d'argent ils avaient jalonné ces kits
ont préféré tôt pour l'instant ici comme
tu es nouveau tu fais pas trop de
préférer j'ai choisi ce thème était
réalisable à 10h au québec
oui tout le monde est charmant et
géraldine a offert un cadeau hier quand
même lui arrive et c'est vrai qu'il m'a
fait super cadeau c'est une carte qu un
femme fin du moyen-âge décrié qui fait
chaud à gaza mais dans certains cas il
est super beau il a trouvé les identités
des boîtes à face aux allégations
erronées ne se voit pas
et le côté de moi je bois frais baba
exactement ça serait bien alors j'ai vu
aussi séparément la sempat lady
maintenant le confinement est
aujourd'hui je te dire ah c'est toi et
ton équipe c'est vrai qu'à derrière qui
a été généreux avec moi parce que je le
dis
il ya même un saint-etienne à 21h et ma
femme est dans la loge la télé mais ils
m'ont dit on va revenir mais toi
d'accord et bah écoute tu nous racontes
ryan